welcome everyone to the International
Spy Museum we are delighted to have you
here this evening and I think you are in
for a delightful evening my name is
Peter earnest I'm the executive director
of the museum I'm very honored to have
all of you here this evening but there's
one or two guests I would particularly
like to invite you to meet and one and
it's such a pleasure because it is a
rare visit not all that common I would
like you to meet the founder of the
International Spy Museum
Milt mauls and his wife Tamar who is the
chairman of our board none of this would
have happened if mild' hadn't had the
idea he served in NSA as a young man and
had the idea of doing something like
this for many years and he did it the
other one I would like you to meet is a
member of our board former chief of
counterintelligence for the Soviet KGB
general Oleg Kalugin yes
and our guest this evening of course as
you know you have come here is Dame
Stella Rimington Dame Stella Rimington
was spent some 35 years in the British
security service from 1969 to 1996
during that period she served in all
three branches both counter-intel Kenner
espionage counter subversion and
counterterrorism and rose to become head
of each of those staffs she then was the
direct the Deputy Director one of the
deputy directors and following a trip
she made to Moscow the first trip that
the British had made to Moscow to meet
the KGB under other circumstances on a
return she was told that she'd been
promoted to director general of mi5 the
British domestic security service she
was the first woman promoted to that
position she was also the first head of
mi5 to be publicly announced the press
had been trying to get a picture of her
for months well they finally got one
because she posed for it
Dame Remington was a great advocate of
openness and transparency transparency
to the public and openness as to the
nature of the service she was the
proponent of that when she was there and
she continued to do that in her
retirement both in her memoirs her
autobiography open secret as well as
presentations speeches and so forth that
she's made subsequently the year that
she retired 1996 in the Honours List for
that year she was named Dame Stella
Rimington commander order of the bath
and that is a title that she has that is
the DCB to this day in 2004 she
published her first novel at risk her
second one in 2006 secret asset and in
2007 illegal action which is the one
that we have here this evening and will
be available for signing after the
presentation
subsequent to her retirement she served
on several boards one of which was of
course Marks & Spencer which are all
familiar with the BG group and I'm very
very honored to say the board of the
International Spy Museum since 2007 we
are indeed very honored to have her on
the board before naming into the board
we of course did a background check she
did very well
I of course asked my colleagues because
you know there's there's the official
things that are said and there's what
people say around the water fund water
fountain and everybody I know gave her a
real thumbs up and I think what finally
solidified it for me was after I wrote
Dame Stella Remington I said dear Dame
Stella Rimington she wrote back a very
cordial reply and at the end of it she
said call me Stella
please join me in welcoming Stella
Rimington
well good evening everybody I'm
delighted to be here at the
International Spy Museum which i think
is one of the most interesting and
lively museums in town but then i would
say that wouldn't as i'm on the board as
you've heard i'm going to talk about my
experiences of my career in mi5 and
really i'm going to talk about how the
threats that that service faces have
changed and how mi5 had to change as
well to cope with them
I joined mi5 as you've heard in the late
1960s and the fact that I joined at all
was a complete fluke because in those
days nobody knew anything about British
intelligence nobody knew who worked
there nobody knew what it was where it
was and in particular of course nobody
knew how you joined and recruitment like
everything else was a secret as I found
out now the website setting out the sort
of jobs that there are available and you
can apply online and they have job
advertisements appearing in the
newspapers and even on the notice boards
of gyms I hear and surprisingly enough
if you google Russian intelligence
service you get a sponsored link for
jobs in mi5
and I think you probably know there's a
very popular TV series which is called
mi5 here and spooks in the United
Kingdom though I must say that I
wouldn't rely on it too much as a source
of information
I was actually recruited to mi5 in India
I'd given up my first profession which
was as a historical archivist to go with
my husband who is a diplomat and he was
posted to the British High Commission in
New Delhi and there I was cheerfully
doing what diplomats wives did in those
days which I must say was not very much
except going to coffee mornings and
appearing in amateur dramatics when
somebody sidled up to me in the British
High Commission compound and tapped me
on the shoulder and said do you want to
be a spy or something like that anyway
and it was the mi5 man in charge of the
small little sort of department which
they had there in those days and he
recruited me as a part-time member of
mi5 as a clerk typist the only
difficulty was that with a degree as I
had an opposed graduate diploma I
couldn't actually type but that didn't
really seem to matter because in those
days people were recruited really for
who they were rather than what they
could do and of course as a diplomat's
wife I was by definition reliable I
thought she's wonderful I knew nothing
at all about mi5 except that I knew that
it had something to do with spies and
there was a lot of spying going on in
those days by both sides in India it was
one of the four fronts really of the
Cold War and I found this absolutely
fascinating so when we came home I
applied for and got a full-time job in
mi5 the UK has got three intelligence
services for those of you who don't know
there's mi5 mi6 and GCHQ
and they're all civilian none of them
have any police powers or any military
powers and none of them are exactly like
any aspect of US intelligence mi5 the
defensive arm and their job is to defend
the country against major threats to our
national security whatever they may be
and obviously they very
on the state of the world at any given
time when I joined the major threat came
from espionage from the Soviet Union and
it's our lives nowadays of course the
major threat comes from terrorists mi5
works very closely with mi6 which is our
foreign intelligence gathering service
which equates broadly but not totally
with the CIA and then we have GCHQ which
equates much more closely with NSA and
together these three services gather
intelligence from many different sources
at home and abroad by all the classical
intelligence gathering means by
intercepting communications
eavesdropping with covert microphones in
the places where people meet to do their
plotting surveillance physically
following people around but the best
sources even in today's technical world
are human beings the terrorists or the
spy deep in the heart of their
organization who can be persuaded to
change sides stay where they are and
work for you effectively to betray their
colleagues and finding those people and
recruiting them and running them is
still an essential part of intelligence
work then of course you've got carefully
to analyze and assess everything that
you've learned decide if you believe it
go out and get more and take action and
this is the key thing at the right
moment you hope to prevent the bomb
going off or the spy getting the secrets
intelligence will never give you the
whole picture by definition so it's
often extremely difficult to decide what
action to take and when to take it in
the Cold War much action came in the
form of disruption try and identify the
foreign intelligence officer who's
working against you in your country try
and recruit them to your side or if you
can't expose them embarrass them get
them expelled from the country nowadays
when terrorists are the main threat
action is much more likely to be in the
form of arrests but arrests will not be
effective unless you've got evidence
that you can use
in court and often of course
intelligence isn't evidence and you
can't use it in court so the dilemma is
acute if you take action too late the
bomb goes off if you take action too
soon you can't hold your suspects and
they get away and may come back another
day when you haven't got any
intelligence at all when we were working
against the IRA as we were for a good
part of my career we tended to let their
operations run on we watched them as
they plotted and planned and really we
watched them write to the moment when
they were planting their bomb and then
they were arrested and of course there
was plenty of evidence now when my
former colleagues are dealing with
suicide bombers with the possibility of
extremely nasty forms of attack the
risks of doing that are deemed to be too
great and the police feel the need to
arrest on the intelligence of intent and
of planning and then of course they've
got to collect evidence afterwards in
order to justify those arrests and bring
these people to court and that's a
problem and that's partly why in the UK
there is a big debate going on at the
moment as the government is seeking
powers to hold suspects in terrorist
cases longer before charging them than
they have been allowed to do in the past
and the other angle to that of course is
the complexity of the data that's now
having to be analyzed as these cases
often have very big international
connections of all kinds so the big
debate goes on between the government
and the supporters of civil liberties
who feel that these powers are not
necessary and breach are hard-won civil
liberties I joined mi5 at the height of
the Cold War an overwhelming stress of
course in those days was from the Soviet
Union and their East European allies and
their efforts at espionage and
subversion as they tried to spread world
communism and undermine Western
democracies their intelligence services
were present in our capitals in large
numbers masquerading as diplomats
journalists Trade Representatives you
name it really
and in those days it was all rather like
a john lecarre a novel for those of you
who read John the Kerry and know about
George Smiley and his colleagues people
were leaving packets of money and hollow
trees on Hampstead Heath in return for
piles of secret documents our jobs
course was to find out what was going on
and stop it and the way we countered
Cold War espionage was through detailed
investigation often over years of the
spy we got results in those days through
my a minut knowledge of the opposing
intelligence services of their people of
the their modus operandi as we called it
so we followed them around we listened
to their telephones we watched their
headquarters in their embassies in our
capitals and we run double agents
against them to try and find out what
they were up to and disrupt them in
those days speed was not nearly as
important as certainty the mi5 I joined
in those days was a static secretive
inward-looking
organization and that attitude was
partly explained by a well-founded fear
of infiltration
I joined not that long after the
Cambridge spies Sylvie Burgess and
MacLean had been exposed and had fled to
Moscow and there were people in British
intelligence and also in the CIA on this
side who were convinced that the whole
of Western intelligence was infiltrated
and penetrated by the KGB and that was a
sort of conviction I suppose supported
by a series of defectors from the Soviet
Union on my side we had Peter Wright who
famously was tried in Australia for
publishing a book called spy capture and
on your side
you had James Angleton in the CIA and
these two work together to create this
sort of sense of real paranoia and
amazingly not long actually before I
joined this culminated in my service in
an investigation of the then director
general for in case he was a spy on no
grounds whatsoever as far as I can see
well presumably he sat quietly in his
office getting on with his work while
this investigation
taking place around him in those days
international contacts international
intelligence contacts were very limited
for us they were limited to the United
States Canada Australia and New Zealand
the trusted friends of the Cold War
because of the same fear of infiltration
that another service you might be
dealing with might be infiltrated in the
UK contacts between ourselves and
government and the civil service were
very limited we even managed to keep the
Treasury at bay in those days on the
grounds that what we were doing was far
too secret for them to know anything
about you couldn't get away with that
nowadays I can tell you there were no
laws or external oversight mechanisms in
the United Kingdom at that time to
govern what we did for people who worked
in the organisation there were very
strict rules about what you could say
about your work and as far as I can
remember it was almost nothing to
anybody about anything really I do beg
you remember there was one rule that you
were allowed to tell your fiance where
you worked but not your boyfriend and I
don't I don't think that that's the rule
that they could operate nowadays
essentially and you could certainly tell
nobody what you did which of course made
social life extremely difficult
particularly for young people who love
to talk about the wonderful job they've
just got for women looking at it from my
point of view now there was another
problem mi5 in those days was operating
not so much a glass ceiling more of a
glass box with walls all round in which
we women were kept
we were regarded as being ok the desk
work for dealing with the papers for
filing and collating and a little bit of
intelligence analysis if we were thought
to be quite bright but certainly not the
sharp end work and certainly not dealing
with human sources the people the best
sources of intelligence before long not
surprisingly we women who were just as
well educated as the men I would say
were pressing to break out of this box
and in an experiment I was the first
woman who was allowed to go on the
course that was teaching the skills that
we needed to
do this human source recruiting and
running and I thought great this is the
breakthrough women are on their way but
when I got on this course it was quite
clear that thinking had only gone so far
and the course was assuming that all the
students would be men because the first
thing you had to do the first exercise
was that you had to go into a pub and I
didn't using some cover story about who
you were and what you were doing you had
to identify anybody you liked in this
pub and try and find out as much as you
possibly could about them and then
unbeknownst to you somebody from the
course was going to come in and blow
your cover story and the test was how
well you dealt with these two angles of
the exercise and I can remember to this
day I was given my pub which was a very
sleazy sort of dump near a Victoria
Station in London I can remember to this
day going into this pub and standing at
the door and surveying the scene it the
pub was all full of men of course they
all seemed to me to be men and dirty
Macs leaving on the bar drinking pints
of beer as though they would be in those
days and I went up to one of these guys
and started chatting him up and it was
quite clear to me that he was just
beginning to think my purpose was
something quite different from
intelligence cover when the guy from the
course came in and I treated him as a
bit of a savior really which was not
quite what was intended so that was the
start for women for many years though
any of the kind of family-friendly
policies that make it easier for women
particularly women with children to work
were resisted part-time work was
regarded as inconceivable job shares had
never been heard of in those days and it
was thought absolutely vital that all
intelligence officers work 24/7 if the
case required it which led of course to
some complicated experiences for me as
my family grew and I ended up with two
small children and my family life and my
professional I've got pretty intertwined
I can remember once I was talking to a
man from one of the East European
embassies in London who was thinking of
defecting and had arranged to meet this
chap in a safe house because obviously
if his side had known what he was doing
is certainly his liberty
possibly his life would have been at
risk and I was just going off to meet
him when the phone on my desk rang and
it was the nanny to say that my younger
daughter II was a baby at the time had
gone into convulsions she had called an
ambulance and would I meet them at the
hospital so had this classic dilemma
well-known and I think to all working
mothers who are you going to let down on
this occasion I managed not to let
anybody down because the safe house was
quite near the hospital
so I by shared good luck actually so I
rushed off to the safe house I explained
to this chap what had happened I
borrowed money from him for all the
taxis involved in the rushing about and
I got to the hospital in time to see the
doctor that guy never did defect in the
end and I've never known whether it was
the apparent shortage of money available
to British intelligence that actually
put him off now of course all the sort
of flexible employment employment
policies that most reasonable companies
have nowadays are in place and there
have now been two women director
generals but with all the modernization
in the world
I think secret organizations still
present complex people and leadership
issues some of the problems of course
our motivation people don't join things
like mi5 for money because we're talking
here about the public service they
joined through a sense of service of
loyalty excitement the importance of the
job they're doing but their successes
are inevitably hidden and their failures
tend to be there for everybody to see in
the form of dead bodies or broken glass
on the pavement you can't use classic
reward mechanisms money and public
acclaim so instead you've got to
generate something else some sense of
satisfaction in a job well done
operations of course are difficult
require difficult decisions and can have
a very dramatic effect if they go wrong
so you've got to manage people in
smallish groups really to ensure they
don't go wrong but if you're over
supervise people who've joined for those
sort of motives that I've described then
they tend to lose their motivation and
then the security of course everybody
has got secrets in their head so you
require
fairly intrusive security people have
got to keep an eye out for colleagues
behaving strangely perhaps but again you
need mutual trust and loyalty of people
are going to support each other in
difficult situations and then
everybody's private life gets mixed up
with their work in the way I've
described so all that needs pretty
careful handling by an alert strong and
visible leadership to create this sense
of belonging almost of a family really
because it's important that people feel
proud and confident in what they belong
to far more important though than the
social change that let women into the
shop and work was the change in the
threat in the 70s and then increasingly
on into the 80s and the 90s a new threat
was beginning to appear and that was the
threat of terrorism which was going to
change everything about the mi5 that I
joined firstly it came from the
situation in Northern Ireland and the
IRA rapidly became one of the best
resourced and the most professional
terrorist organizations in the world
thanks in large part to Colonel Gaddafi
who provided them with arms and large
quantities of money during the 1980s and
then at the same time we had what we
then called international terrorism
firstly in the form of national groups
like the Red Brigades assorted
Palestinian groups and by the 80s if you
remember those of you who are old enough
there were hijackings kidnappings the
murder of political opponents by some
countries on our streets even by the
time I left mi5 in 1996
75 percent of our work was against
terrorist error ISM though of course
espionage still goes on spying never
ends but the targets change as the world
changes and the focus of Western counter
espionage work nowadays is much more
likely to be Iran perhaps and Syria but
it is Bulgaria Poland and Hungary but of
course some old enmities die hard as
we've seen from the death of Alexander
Litvinenko in London which is widely
assumed
was carried out by the KGB and I read in
the newspapers just before I left London
that my former service is now
complaining that there are as many
Russian intelligence officers in London
now as the where during the Cold War and
that they're having to divert resources
from fighting terrorism to working out
what they're all up to so the world
perhaps doesn't change as much as we
might think it should so going back to
terrorism though September the 11th 2001
seemed to some people like the beginning
of a new era of horror in the world's
history to those of us who'd been
working in the field in the UK against
terrorism for a long time we saw it
really more as a stage possibly the
worst stage so far of a phenomenon that
had gripped the world for more than 30
years when we first faced terrorism we
tried to deal with it in the same way as
we dealt with the Soviet spies but it
soon became clear that countering
terrorism requires a completely
different response good intelligence is
just as important but reliable
intelligence is often very difficult to
obtain there's often lots of what you
might call information circulating
around but you can't take action on
everything you hear or the country and
the world would be brought to a halt
with security alerts times always short
and rapid judgments have got to be made
about what's true and what isn't and
what you can safely ignore and what
you've got to take action on and it's
about balancing risks and it's a
difficult thing to do and it requires
nerve and resolution because the penalty
of getting it wrong is huge
might be loss of life on a large scale
or massive destruction of property and
it will be certain blame as the media
picks over everything that you've done
or haven't done in the quiet aftermath
and judges it it's a very different
thing from the quiet slow secretive
world of counterespionage today's
terrorists I think presents an even more
difficult problem than the ones I'm used
to dealing with when we were combating
the IRA we
knew where they were they were a
structured organization and very soon we
knew who they were we knew what they
wanted they wanted the Brits out of
Northern Ireland so we knew broadly what
their targets would be anything to do
with the British state so they murdered
the military officers they blew up mrs.
Thatcher and her cabinet when they were
having their Party conference and nearly
killed them all and their mortared
number 10 Downing Street when the then
Prime Minister John Major was holding a
cabinet meeting but we also knew what
they would not do the IRA were not
suicide bombers they wanted to escape
with their lives so the worst forms of
attacks chemical biological even nuclear
they would never have contemplated today
terrorists I think are very different
and I believe that the terrorist has
changed even since 9/11 it seems clear
that al Qaeda hasn't only survived the
war on terror but has become almost what
you might describe as a global franchise
with fluid networks of people who are
trained to carry out attacks and can
deliver these centrally planned attacks
often on European streets in particular
at present in the UK there are groups of
young men in our cities in the UK born
and educated there British citizens
who've developed for some reason a deep
hatred for the country that they live in
and its people and they're sympathetic
to and sometimes directly directed by al
Qaeda but they don't belong to
organizations with headquarters like
intelligence services that you can
target in the same way as we did in the
Cold War and their fanaticism makes it
very difficult to recruit sources among
them to get information and they don't
have precise objectives either they're
not interested in political solutions
they just seem intent on killing the
largest number of unconnected people
that they possibly can
workers going to work on a bus or an
underground train or an aeroplane so
it's very hard to predict their targets
it means everybody
target and everybody's got to get
involved in security measures everybody
wants to know what's being done to
protect them and businesses and
individuals as well as the government is
a target terrorism in my opinion sad to
say is here to stay for the foreseeable
future
and I think that the declaration of a
war on terrorism leading as it did to
the war in Iraq and everything that's
followed from that unfortunately has all
fed this fanaticism and strength of
terror we've recently been told in the
UK that mi5 my former service was aware
of 200 networks in the United Kingdom
alone and that they were attempting to
disrupt nearly 30 separate plots to
carry out mass casualty attacks and
that's in spite of everything that's
being done against them there have been
I must say on the other side a number of
successful disruptions the people have
been put on trial thanks to good
intelligence work but however much
resources put in to counterterrorism
there's net it's never going to be
possible to disrupt all these plans and
yesterday of course was the second
anniversary of what we in the UK called
7-7 which was the series of bombs on the
London Underground and I think just to
sum up on this you've only got to
reflect really on a chilling video which
was made by one of those bombers and in
that video he said what you have
witnessed now is only the beginning of a
string of attacks that will continue and
become stronger we are a hundred percent
committed to the cause of Islam we love
death the way you love life and even if
a lot of that is wishful thinking and
bravado it does look as though this is a
phenomenon that we're going to be living
with for quite a long time to come so
the need to tackle terrorism brought all
sorts of changes to us in mi5 and in
particular it required more openness
openness with foreign services to share
intelligence and openness at home with
our courts and with government ministers
I became director of
Counterterrorism just a few days before
Lockerbie when Pan Am 103 was brought
down by a bomb over Lockerbie in
Scotland there was huge pressure on us
for a quick answer and at the same time
the IRA was trying to kill British
soldiers in Germany and then when that
began not to be successful because of
good intelligence they moved to the
streets of Great Britain I used to have
to go regularly across to number 10
Downing Street to talk to the Prime
Minister and update him on the situation
and it wasn't always very satisfactory I
would say this is the beginning of our
openness the sort of thing I sometimes
used to have to say to him was well
Prime Minister we know that the IRA are
about to bring in a large truck bomb we
don't know which port it's coming in at
we don't know when it's coming in and we
don't know what the target is but Prime
Minister I thought you should know it's
not what you want to have to tell the
boss I can tell you but to do him credit
he reacted in exactly the right way he
used to sort of close his eyes and
leaned back in his chair and say oh well
Stiller do your best which was exactly
what we did actually and very often
those bombs didn't go off because we did
manage to get prior intelligence as the
eighties turned into the 90s there was
another massive change for our
intelligence services when all of a
sudden with surprising speed the Cold
War came to an end and people started
saying we don't need those intelligence
services anymore they're all about the
Cold War but we knew we were needed more
than ever because of the threat from
terrorism in an early move we made
contact with our former enemies in the
services of Eastern Europe and we I
found myself sitting in their
headquarters exchanging stories with
them about what we'd been trying to do
to them during the Cold War and as you
can imagine it was a great and very very
exciting time the oddest of all I have
to say was my visit to Moscow in
December 1991 that Peter alluded to to
make our first contact with KGB it came
about because the cotton was the man
whom yeltsin had put in charge of the
KGB and he I believe was a true Democrat
really wanted to change things and he
met the British Foreign Secretary and he
knew that we had just been legislating
for our intelligence services in Britain
and he asked whether we could send over
some people to talk to the KGB about how
you must behave in their democracy and I
went with a couple of colleagues to do
just that and we found ourselves in the
Lubyanka which is their headquarters
almost lecturing a long line of
hard-faced KGB officers on things like
laws and how you must behave in the
democracy it was quite clear to me that
they had absolutely no intention of
behaving in any way differently from the
way they'd always behaved and I think it
was not a meeting of minds in any way
because we saw that as a moment of hope
really a moment when the world could get
together again after the Cold War but I
think they saw it as a moment of failure
and certainly liaison between the two
services never really took off in the
way it did with the East European
services shortly after I got back from
that trip my appointment as director
general was announced and we've been or
I'd been through a lot of change by them
during my working life but I was about
to experience a personal change which
was going to alter my life and that of
my family radically because I was told
at the same time as Peter said almost by
the way that my name was going to be
made public on appointment the
government thought that this was a good
openness announcement and also of course
that it was a good equality announcement
because I was a woman imagine what it's
like to be suddenly thrust into the
limelight after a career in a secret
organisation like everybody I'd created
a kind of carapace a cover of anonymity
and it's still only the name of the
Director General which has made public
if you don't tell people what you do it
makes it very difficult to have the kind
of casual sort of social relationships
which most people take for granted if
you accept your neighbors invitation to
Christmas drinks you have to prepare for
the moment which will inevitably come
when somebody says and what do you do
and you either make
have some story for the evening about
how you buy boots for the army or you
work for a cosmetics company or
something or you rush around the room so
fast that nobody ever has a chance to
talk to you at all which is not very
satisfactory whatever you've decided to
be for the evening though you can
guarantee that the first person you talk
to is going to be an expert in just that
thing so people become weary of social
situations and close friendships tend to
be developed within the ring of secrecy
which is not necessarily a very good
thing either so one day for me that kind
of anonymity turned to fame in a rather
dramatic way the press had this sudden
announcement about a woman in a man's
job as they saw it with no photographs
to go with it because it was at a time
when the IRA was very active and our
tabloids never the most subtle of people
went into freefall in their excitement I
was clearly not James Bond and I didn't
look like smiley should look either so
their first reaction was to try and get
me back where I belonged which was in
the kitchen and we had headlines like
housewife super spy and another effort
was mother of two gets tough with
terrorists they found out quite easily
where we lived because we'd always lived
just ordinarily relying on my anonymity
came and camped outside the house to the
great annoyance of the neighbors who
suddenly realized that this quiet lady
who'd lived on their street for the last
10 years was not what she seemed to be
and presented a risk and eventually when
one newspaper published a photograph of
our house on the front page we had to
move overnight and start to live a fully
Clover to life for our own safety which
as you can imagine put great strains on
my daughter's particularly the younger
one who was then I think she was about
17 still living at home and she then had
to be extremely careful who she invited
to the house and who she could give her
telephone number to her particular worry
was she had a little car and she was it
was registered in a false name and she
was very worried when she went out in
the evening what if it broke down
or she got stopped by the police for
some reason and before she went out she
used to say to me now just tell me again
mum Who am I and I seem to kind of sum
up the whole situation really but all
this publicity actually changed the
public profile of mi5 which now emerged
into the open with an identifiable
leader and so we decided to profit by
this publicity and present a more
up-to-date idea of what mi5 is and what
it really does and what it doesn't do
and counter the negative image that we'd
acquired as a result of never saying
anything at all in public so we invited
the editors of the major newspapers in
for lunch much to their surprise we put
out a booklet explaining the work of a
security service in a democracy and I
gave a high profile lecture on BBC
television the subject is still a very
current subject it was is there a
conflict between security and democracy
and that's a debate that's still going
on in the United Kingdom at the moment
and it did start a very good debate in
the in the sensible newspapers but it
started a not very sensible debate as
well and one journalist wrote that I had
very large ears and that these must be
very useful in covert communication so
after so much change what lies ahead in
the security field well as I've said it
looks as though terrorism from al Qaeda
and associated groups will continue and
unfortunately escalate possibly until
some answer is found to some really
difficult issues the israel-palestine
situation in particular the extreme
inequalities in education and economic
situation between countries the lack of
integration of minority groups in our
cities particular in the UK the Iraq war
and to a lesser extent the war in
Afghanistan I think all that created
this chronic crisis between parts of
Muslim youth and the West so we're now
facing a complex problem but our
intelligence services and our police
forces will get better at dealing with
it and they are doing all the time
thank goodness though it's a
but I no longer have to deal with
because I retired from mi5 12 years ago
now and I've reinvented myself in
various ways as you've heard as a as an
independent director as the chairman of
a charity at the business mentor but
mainly nowadays as an author and I wrote
my autobiography in 2001 open secret to
a certain amount of shock horror from
parts of the media and parts of the
establishment in my country they were
not sure if they were shocked that
because I was about to reveal the
nation's secrets or shocked when they
found out that I wasn't doing that when
I submitted my first draft for clearance
as I was required to do some people
within the system decided they were
going to put a stop to this and put the
unedited draft in a brown paper envelope
and sent it round to one of our most
tabloid of tabloid newspapers the son
who didn't know what to do with it so
they put it in another brown paper
envelope and sent it back in a taxi to
number 10 Downing Street with a press
photographer and that caused an enormous
amount of us and are now writing novels
and illegal action which is at the back
of the room is the most recent to be
published in the United States and it
features a not surprisingly you will
hear a female mi5 officer as a heroine
and the question is if she modelled on
me and the answer is well obviously she
is in part at least and I do I must
admit use some of my own experiences as
a basis for the plot so really I think
that's all I have to say and I'm very
happy to take any questions but before I
finish I'll just tell you one story
which shows that if you spend a good
long time working in a secret
organization you never quite lose the
aura of secrecy
shortly after I retired I went to a
dinner given by a major British company
for the diplomatic corps in London and I
found myself sitting at the same table
as some very senior British businessmen
and the ambassador of a former Soviet
bloc country and I saw this guy watching
me very carefully
all through the first course and when
the second course came along he
suddenly announced to the whole table
she knows the names of all my mistresses
and there was a free song went around
the table and all these British
businessmen were looking at me out of
the corner of their eyes and they were
wondering and I knew what they were
wondering they were wondering if I knew
the names of all their mistresses too
and quite honestly that's something I
like to keep them wondering about thank
you very much
last novel which will be back to the
room and she's kindly agreed to sign
copies I noticed in the copy for this
the promotional copy the heroine is
described as an ambitious aggressive
woman is that correct
I tell us they should be delighted to
take questions we have microphones on
either side of the room so I would ask
you to wait to the microphone so
everyone can hear your questions and
I'll try and work we'll try and work
both sides of the room right here
who is up here up front who has a mic we
have the mic back there I will start
with that one and then take one up here
go ahead please sir I always think of
mi5 as Walsingham's airs and given that
the 400th anniversary of the Gunpowder
Plot past not so long ago my question is
are there any lessons of applicable
today from the historical experience
with Islamic terrorism from the record
of Roman Catholic terrorism for four
centuries ago you're right that mi5 are
Walsingham's as Walsingham was Queen
Elizabeth's spy master and I think that
the techniques that Walter employed are
the same techniques amazingly enough
that are employed today Walsingham had
agents in place here is intercepting
communications particularly to Mary
Queen of Scots and you know who is
employing all the sort of classic covert
activities one thing that we don't do
nowadays though is hang draw and quarter
people which he went in for in a big way
so yeah I think we've we I don't think
we've learned from him but we sort of
carried on his tradition I think yes
okay I have one right here and then your
next and then I'll come over here
excellent talk thank you that was a lot
of fun thank you
what was the perception of the British
public to mi5 and mi6 following the
Iraqi invasion Prime Minister Blair
supported us almost instantly and
wholeheartedly and as an American I
loved him for that but I'm wondering
what sort of flack he got from the
public or what am i five and six got
from the poetry for advising him yeah
the answer to that is a lot of flack
from the public and Tony Blair's
reputation I don't think ever really
recovered in the United Kingdom from
going along with the war in Iraq what
the big one of the biggest
demonstrations that ever took place on
the streets of London was against the
troops entering into the war in Iraq the
the big fuss of course came about
because of the intelligence being
inaccurate and in in Britain a dossier
was published for the very first time
time containing secret intelligence and
of course the secret intelligence turned
out not to be accurate so there were two
inquiries into that it was particularly
mi6 that got the flack for that because
the sources of the so-called
intelligence came from Iraq and it was
not it was not correct so it did damage
will it damage British intelligence
altogether I think and it will take some
time to recover you know one could go
into the reasons why all that happened
and there are many in complex but it was
not a good time for the intelligence
services or for the Prime Minister what
are we hearing them yeah at the
university research librarian I did my
research on you before I came and I
noticed that you made a big thing of the
openness and this is all of course
before 9/11 I'm wondering now if this
administration in this country went in
the entire opposite direction we went to
more secrecy I'm wondering if you were
advising a new administration so next
year and on the basis of your experience
with the openness and after 9/11 would
you change anything in your view
of openness now I don't think I would I
felt that it was very important that
they the huge sort of blanket of secrecy
that had covered British intelligence
for so long should be drawn back a
little because the public needed to be
confident
I thought particularly in our domestic
security service that they knew who the
sort of things that they did and
particularly the sort of things they
didn't do after many many allegations
had been made about us spying on trade
unionists and suchlike and all that was
able to to fester because we never said
anything about ourselves so I still
think that it's very important for
enough to be said about our secret
intelligence area for the public to
understand what it's all about
but that means of course making sure
that you draw the line in the right
place never to talk about operations or
details of methods or people etc so I
think it's a fine balance but you've got
to get you've got to get the confidence
of the media and that we worked very
hard at by assuring them that we weren't
going to tell them everything but what
we were not going to do is tell them
lies and I think that was a very very
important point to make right at the
outset so don't think I'd change things
no yes right back here Kelsey all the
way back in the middle
the strides that you made in your field
been followed by other women or are you
one of the kind yes they have been
followed by the time I left mi5 the
service was Half Men and half women
although they were not even the women
were not evenly spread through the ranks
but nevertheless they were coming up and
there has been another female in charge
of the service since I left so yes it
goes on and women have proved that they
can do the work just as well as men they
do it differently but that's good
because it provides diversity but yeah
it's going forward I'm pleased to say
I'm back there ma'am Elsie over there
yeah over here yes right here and then
over here
Kelsey up here yeah yeah what first of
all thank you you're a wonderful
storyteller and you make me very jealous
I don't have a British accent but the
question I have a comment you made about
the really the causes of terrorism and
you listed a litany of causes many of
which are are common and are frequently
invoked what what I didn't hear was sort
of an explanation of the ideological
underpinnings of radical Islamist
terrorism and what really is a pervasive
ideology that's motivating both Sunni
and Shiite terrorism is that something
that you feel is a factor if so is it a
significant factor and if so do you
think we have a very firm grasp of
really the ideological motivation of
Islamic terrorism no I don't think we do
have a firm grasp of it and I certainly
haven't got a firm grasp of it and I
find it it difficult to understand how
many different interpretations there are
of you know the the Islamic religion and
how some people will say that terrorism
is justified killing the enemies of
Islam is justified others will say it
isn't and there seems to me to be a very
very confused message coming out and
particularly you see this in the United
Kingdom where the government has been
feeling around for four
allies as you might say spokespeople
within the community to be able to talk
to and has not been very successful in
finding that so I can't answer that
question I don't know what what the
underpinnings are and I'm not sure that
in the West we understand it and I'm not
sure that we're having it explained to
us very coherently either yes over here
Kelsey was back here yes you explained
that there now about fifty percent women
and mi5 the British intelligence
services were traditionally very old
school tie so I'm curious to what degree
do you have other kinds of diversity now
in British intelligence different
socio-economic groups different ethnic
groups and I'm assuming that the part of
going online is to reach out to people
who didn't go to boarding schools and
their schools high image went out quite
a long time ago where everybody came
from either Oxford or Cambridge and had
been to public school that went out
certainly a few years after I joined I
would say and I think every university
is represented in the intelligence
officer grade there has been a big
effort to recruit people from the ethnic
minority groups and particularly this is
essential really for linguists and for
surveillance officers if you're doing
surveillance operations in areas of
mainly lived in by ethnic groups you
need surveillance officers who are from
the same group so yeah there's been a
big effort it's not always easy
because from some of those communities
joining something like an intelligence
service is not necessarily the most
desirable profession same with the
police actually but certainly a big
effort is going into that and it is it
has changed
in the build-up to the Iraqi war the
polarization of intelligence played a
big role particularly within the agency
but also as well from the White House
does the British community faced such
polarization problems I think there were
similar problems in the UK as well a as
I said a dossier was published for the
very first time containing secret
intelligence which was published at the
behest of the government and which
contain which turned out to be
misleading and I think it was widely
felt that the too much pressure had been
put on the Joint Intelligence Committee
which does this fundamental analysis to
publish a dossier and the investigate
the inquiry which was conducted by a
former cabinet secretary afterwards did
say that far too much weight was put on
intelligence by the government so yep
that whole issue runs and ran through in
the United Kingdom in broadly the same
way as it did here really
although another excellent speech on the
recent story yesterday about Alexander
is that koneko is there anything new
about that wasn't it known that the
Russian government had ordered his
killing and why did they want him killed
I don't ask them I think that the answer
to that I assume they wanted him killed
because he was making critical remarks
particularly about his former service
his former well the KGB as was he had
been saying that he thought that they
were responsible for setting up a number
of terrorist operations in Russia and
therefore I assume that they thought
that some you know this man had better
be silenced the pretty thorough
investigation was done of this trail of
polonium as I'm sure you know wishes the
substance with which he was killed which
indicated to the British investigators
who the person was who had actually
killed him and there is a an
international warrant out for the arrest
of this person but the chances of him
coming to the UK to be prosecuted I
would say were nil one ratio
thank you very much have a question
regarding your your view on terrorism
and that is how concerned should we all
be that the Western democracies are you
know spending tens of billions of
dollars in anti-terrorism activities
intelligence and operations and such at
the same time those same democracies are
sending hundreds of billions of dollars
to many of the countries by purchasing
oil that are you know not the best
friends of those democracies and you
have so much money sloshing around there
is some of that going to leak out to
people who are definitely unfriendly to
us I mean isn't this a part of our
energy policies not just a security
policy I think that that's a very
difficult question to answer I mean to
the amount of money that we're spending
on protecting ourselves against
terrorism I think that's a you know one
can debate quite frankly how much of the
all these sort of anti-terrorist
measures that we are all facing now are
absolutely necessary I think one of the
problems with governments is that they
wish to create a situation where nobody
can possibly blame them if something
goes wrong so particularly in the UK
we're facing ever-increasing measures in
the you know and under the name of anti
counter terrorism particularly you know
protecting us on the streets there is a
big debate going on about how much of
that is necessary and whether it's not
just the government trying to make sure
that it can't possibly be criticized as
far as I'm in the oil situation goes I
don't know I'm not competent to answer
that and it doesn't it seems to me that
it's um you know it's something that's
it's going to go on regardless because
we all need we all need oil and oil
comes from places that are not
necessarily you know the most wonderful
wonderfully governed on earth and I
think that situation is something that
is going to go on and we'll just have to
be managed all the way on the back
why don't we you eluded a new talk to
the debate back home about the extension
of potential
trialed 42 days do you think that's
justified or that it could possibly be
counterproductive in the long term I was
trying to avoid giving an opinion on
this because as you know that debate has
turned into a can party political issue
in the United Kingdom and if you say you
are in favor of it oh you're not in
favor of it one or the other political
party is going to seize on you and say
they're on our side so I'm quite frankly
if you don't mind would not came to
answer that or it will appear in the
newspaper that I'm supporting over there
the government or the opposition a good
candid answer okay last questions all
right fine Dame Stella Rimington thank
you so much